hi perhaps you recognize me it's your
favorite president
and i'm standing in front of the oval
office at the white house
which is always an exciting place to be
i got back
a day ago from walter reed medical
center i spent four days there
and didn't have to i could have stayed
at the white house but the doctors said
because you're president
let's do it i said fine you tell me what
to do and i'm going to listen these are
great professionals
they've done a fantastic job and by the
way not only at walter reed all over the
country we have the greatest doctors in
the world we have the greatest nurses
the greatest first responders law
enforcement by the way
incredible firefighters everybody
they're just great we have great people
this is a great country
but i spent four days there and i went
in i wasn't feeling so hot
and within a very short period of time
they gave me regeneron it's called
regeneron
and other things too but i think this
was the key but they gave me regeneron
and it was like unbelievable i felt good
immediately i felt as good
three days ago as i do now so i just
want to say
we have regeneron we have a very similar
drug from
eli lilly and they're coming out and
we're trying to get them
on an emergency basis we've uh
authorized it i've authorized it
and if you're in the hospital and you're
feeling really bad
i think we're going to work it so that
you get them and you're going to get
them free
and especially if you're a senior we're
going to get you in there quick we have
hundreds of thousands of doses that are
just about ready
i have emergency use authorization
all set and we got to get it signed now
and
you're going to get better you're going
to get better really fast this is things
that nobody even thought of
a few months ago the job that the
scientists the labs
everybody have done is incredible in
addition to that you have
various other drugs that help
a lot but these i view these and now
they call them therapeutic
but to me it wasn't therapeutic it just
made me better
okay i call that a cure so i want to get
these things done
so we have to get them done we have to
get them approved i want to get them to
the hospitals where people are feeling
badly that's much more important to me
than the vaccine
but on the vaccines we have many
companies that are in final stages for
the vaccines
johnson and johnson moderna pfizer all
great
companies but many of them and we're
going to have a great vaccine very very
shortly i think we should have it before
the election but frankly the politics
gets involved and that's okay
they want to play their games it's going
to be right after the election
but we did it nobody else nobody else
would have been able to do it
the fda has acted as quickly as
they've ever acted in history there's
never been a time and no president's
ever pushed him like i pushed him either
to be honest with you
but the fda is approving things in a
matter of weeks it used to take a matter
of years
so we have these drugs eli lilly and
the others that are so good but they are
in my opinion remember this they're
going to say
that they're therapeutic and i guess
they are therapeutic
some people don't know how to define
therapeutic i view it different
it's a cure for me i walked in i didn't
feel good
a short 24 hours later i was feeling
great i want to get out of the hospital
and that's what i want for everybody i
want everybody
to be given the same treatment as your
president
because i feel great i feel like perfect
so i think this was the blessing from
god that i caught it
this was a blessing in disguise i caught
it
i heard about this drug i said let me
take it it was my suggestion i said let
me take it
and it was incredible the way it worked
incredible
and i think if i didn't catch it we'd be
looking at that like a number of other
drugs but
it really did a fantastic job i want to
get for you
what i got and i'm going to make it free
you're not going to pay for it
it wasn't your fault that this happened
it was china's fault
and china is going to pay a big price
what they've done to this country
china is going to pay a big price what
they've done to the world
this was china's fault and just remember
that
so we're going to get you the drug it's
going to be free we're going to get it
into the hospitals as soon as you can as
soon as we can
and you'll see some amazing things
happen because we have our military
is doing the distribution it's called
logistics
and they deliver hundreds of thousands
of troops in a matter of
days this is easy stuff for them our
generals already we're waiting for the
emergency use authorization and
the drug companies have just made a lot
of it
so hopefully this is going to be not
just a therapeutic it's going to be much
more than a therapeutic
you're going to get better you're going
to get better fast just like i did
so again a blessing in disguise good
luck
you